200 Milliarden Euro der doppelbums
klingt eigentlich super das
Entlastungspaket die
gaspreisbremse ja es ist ein neues
gigantisches Hilfspaket für sinkende
Energiepreise das Ziel von Kanzler
Scholz egal wie groß sie
Herausforderungen sind Deutschland
kriegt das hin jeder und jeder kommt gut
durch den Winter aber die Opposition
kritisiert fehlt den fehlenden Plan für
die Verteilung bei einem drohenden
gasmangel
Gelegenheit gesagt die Maßnahmen die wir
ergreifen sind ein Bums man kann sagen
dass es hier ein doppelbums es soll dazu
beitragen dass jetzt schnell zügig und
für alle schnell feststellbar die Preise
sinken für Energie so dass sich niemand
Sorgen machen muss wenn er an den Herbst
und im Winter denkt wenn er Weihnachten
denkt und dann das nächste Jahr und dann
die Rechnung auch die hohen Rechnung die
einige jetzt bereits bekommen haben als
Abschlagszahlung wenn sich dann wieder
reduzieren können das ist das konkrete
ziel der Maßnahme und der Förderung die
wir uns vorgenommen haben ja aber
trotzdem blicken ganz viele Menschen mit
Angst in diesen Winter heute Nachmittag
bereiten sich die Ministerpräsidenten
mit dem Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz Thema
dann die geplante gaspreisbremse weitere
Entlastungsmaßnahmen die Gasspeicher
sind zwar voll aber wiegen wir uns in
einer falschen Sicherheit ja da sagt
zumindest die Opposition der Vorwurf es
Fehler an einem Plan was bei einem
gasmangel dann wirklich passiert
darüber sprechen wir jetzt und zwar mit
unionsfraktionsvize Jens Spahn der uns
zugeschaltet ist schön guten Tag Herr
spannend ja im Falle einer
Mangelsituation gibt es also keinen Plan
keiner weiß dann wer wie viel von den
Speichern von dem Gas bekommt
nun zuerst einmal wissen wir gar nicht
wie viel in den Speichern auch für
Deutschland für den deutschen Markt die
deutschen Verbraucher vorgesehen ist der
Bund hat ja fast 20 Milliarden Euro zur
Verfügung gestellt um die gaspeicher zu
füllen das ist das Steuerzahlergeld der
deutschen und deswegen sollte jetzt auch
sichergestellt sein dass dieses
eingespeicherte Gas eben auch jetzt im
Herbst und Winter für Deutschland für
die deutschen Verbraucher zur Verfügung
steht es würde ja auch die Preise
stabilisieren Ruhe in den Markt geben
wenn es mal einen Plan gäbe einen
nachvollziehbaren welches Gas sowohl in
den Speichern als auch über ja bereits
gebuchte lng-terminals sich mal die sind
ja über Wochen jetzt schon fest gebucht
die Kapazitäten was davon nach
Deutschland kommt was für die Versorgung
in Deutschland für Industrie und für die
privaten Haushalte zur Verfügung steht
all das ist unklar und deswegen wünsche
ich mir einfach sehr und ich glaube das
wünschen sich viele andere auch dass wir
nicht Doppel Wumms Aussagen in der
Überschrift bekommen sondern einfach mal
konkrete Zahlen und Planungen wie könnte
der denn jetzt aussehen wie müsste denn
dieser ausspeicherplan ihrer Meinung
nach jetzt aussehen
in dem man zum Beispiel schon mal auch
für die nächsten Kalenderwochen auch Gas
verkauft aus den Speichern für den Markt
zur Verfügung stellt der Gasmarkt
funktioniert ja nicht nur so dass man
sozusagen für heute heute Gas kauft
sondern die Versorger oder die Industrie
kaufen jetzt auch schon für Januar
Februar März und weiter darüber hinaus
Gas ein und je nachdem wie viel davon
aus den Speichern auch zur Verfügung
steht bestimmt das den Preis mit und
deswegen wünsche ich mir eben dass diese
Bundesregierung mit dem von ich sage es
noch einmal den Steuerzahlern bezahlten
Gas auch mal einen Plan hat wann was
ausgespeichert wird wann wird es
kritisch in der Versorgung in
Deutschland unter welchen Umständen Wald
möglicherweise zu wenig Gas zur
Verfügung steht das sind eben alles wie
gesagt bisher nur Überschriften nach dem
Motto wir kommen da schon irgendwie
durch ohne dass das unter Licht wird das
gilt übrigens auch für die Bezahlbarkeit
der Gaspreis Deckel der gasgrundbedarf
um den geht es ja die Haushalte müssen
einfach mal wissen wie Gas können Sie
wie viel Kilowattstunden Gas in den
nächsten Wochen in diesem Winter zu
welchem Preis für sich einplanen ich
weiß nicht ob es die Bundesregierung
schon gemerkt hat aber der Herbst hat
schon begonnen der Winter ist kurz vor
der Tür die Leute haben angefangen ihre
Heizung hoch zu drehen aber sie haben
nicht den Hauch von Planungssicherheit
und das schafft sozialen und Frieden das
sehen wir ja auch etwa auf den
Demonstrationen ja und wir sehen auch
das ganz viele auch Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer die auch uns Anschreiben bei
den trudeln jetzt nämlich die
Gasrechnungen ein und die blicken mit
ganz großer Sorge in einen kalten Winter
und fragen sich wie Sie das bezahlen
sollen und fragen sich natürlich auch
was passiert denn wenn wir wirklich in
eine Mangelsituation kommen und dann
verteilt werden muss wie sollte da
priorisiert werden zwischen
Privathaushalten zwischen Unternehmen
und viele fürchten auch komme ich da
überhaupt irgendwie zum Zug
nach europäischem Recht das lässt sich
übrigens nicht nur in Deutschland lösen
deswegen wäre es ihm wichtig dass wir
auch mit unseren europäischen Nachbarn
darüber Abkommen schließen
solidaritätsverträge auch die sind seit
Monaten eigentlich schon überfällig und
noch nicht geschlossen aber nach
europäischem Recht sind die privaten
Haushalte prioritär geschützt
Krankenhäuser soziale Einrichtungen auch
aber eben zum Beispiel bestimmte Teile
der Industrie nicht und auch hier wäre
es wichtig um Planungssicherheit zu
geben wenn es etwas detailliertere
Kriterien gäbe der Bundesnetzagentur die
ja dafür zuständig ist als Behörde wer
unter welchen Umständen kein Gas mehr
bekommen würde der Leiter der
Bundesnetzagentur hat die Tage gesagt
den gasmangel würden wir erst erkennen
wenn wir eigentlich schon gar nichts
mehr dran ändern können wenn er also
sicher kommt das klingt mir noch nicht
so als wenn wir wirklich wüssten wie
dieser Winter wird und was dann eben auf
die
gasverbraucherindustrie wie private
Haushalte zukommt ich weiß ich will noch
mal sagen ist eine Krise es ändert sich
gerade stündlich was und eine Regierung
muss flexibel reagieren das kritisiere
ich nicht werden wir auch nie
kritisieren aber es gibt dem andere
Dinge die kann man rechtzeitig tun man
hätte schon längst ein gasgrundbedarf
einführen können dass diskutieren wir
seit sechs Monaten man weiß jetzt schon
wie viel Gas in den Speichern man im
Winter nutzen kann man könnte planen
wann man welches einsetzt man weiß jetzt
schon was über die lngs an Gas für
Deutschland kommen wird das ist alles
gebucht bis weit ins nächste Jahr hinein
aber es gibt eben keine Transparenz ich
kritisiere nicht dass man kurzfristig
reagieren muss was zu kritisieren ist
dass die Dinge die man längerfristig
planen könnte nicht geplant werden
zumindest nicht transparent und das
schafft Unsicherheit sie haben das eben
gerade ersparen auch angesprochen viele
Menschen sind auch gestern am Tag der
Einheit auf die Straße gegangen in
vielen Städten war das eine wilde
Mischung muss man sagen aus
corona-leugnern rechts und links aber
eben auch Menschen die sich Sorgen
machen um ihre Zukunft die sich Sorgen
machen ob sie die Rechnungen noch
bezahlen können das ging ihnen mit
diesen Bildern die wir jetzt auch zeigen
durch den Kopf aber auch durchs Herz
ich wir spüren das hier alle auch im
Bekanntenkreis das eine sind diejenigen
die protestieren demonstrieren aber sind
auch viele weit darüber hinaus Millionen
Menschen die einfach Sorge haben vor
diesem Winter die wissen dass wir
niemand so stellen können als gäbs
diesen Krieg in Europa diese Krise nicht
das wissen viele die aller allermeisten
wollen auch solidarisch mit der Ukraine
und den tapferen Volk sein dass seine
Freiheit verteidigt aber sie sagen eben
ich brauche hier auch Sicherheit für
mich für meine Familie für meine
Bäckerei für den Handwerksbetrieb und
deswegen wäre der Gas Grundbedarf so
wichtig unser Vorschlag ist ja zum
Beispiel 75% des vorjahresverbrauches zu
maximal 12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde dann
könnte wirklich jeder mit dem
Taschenrechner für sich ausrechnen was
in diesen Winter erwartet und ich glaube
diese sehr einfache aber sehr wirksame
Maßnahme würde schon viel viel
Sicherheit geben und damit auch mehr
sozialen Frieden
mehr Transparenz mehr Planbarkeit einen
richtigen Plan der ampelregierung das
fordert Jens Spahn vielen herzlichen
Dank Ihnen für dieses Gespräch
[Musik]